我今天看到一個案例，真的讓我很意外，感覺跟我們一般理解的消費行為完全不同。
怎麼說？是哪方面的創新？現在的創新很多，但有時候感覺只是換個包裝。
韓國出現一種「純瀏覽購物」的網站，原文叫「dopamine sites」。這些網站就是讓你上去逛街、選商品、加到購物車、填地址、下訂單，甚至可以追蹤物流。
等等，這裡我有疑問。既然能下訂單、追蹤物流，那不就是正常的網購嗎？
差別就在於，你不會真的付款，商品也不會真的寄到你家。整個過程沒有金錢交易，也沒有包裹送達。
什麼？那這樣做有什麼意義？消費者什麼都沒買到，只是瀏覽一堆不存在的東西？這種模式怎麼可能撐得下去？
這就是有趣的地方。原文裡有提到，有人在這個網站上訂了 4 萬多美金的百達翡麗手錶，還有愛馬仕包、蒂芙尼鑽戒什麼的，但他們其實不需要，也根本買不起。
所以就是讓大家過過乾癮嗎？這種精神層面的滿足感，能帶來什麼商業價值？感覺很難變現。
其實這反映了現代人對「體驗」和「心理滿足」的新需求。消費者享受的是那種策展、追蹤的購物樂趣，而不是實際擁有商品。
這種行為讓我很困惑。如果我是電商業者，我會想，這不就是把我的流量都變成沒付錢的瀏覽嗎？營收從哪來？
其實這就像我們以前逛櫥窗、或者在購物網站把東西加到購物車又不結帳一樣。只是這種行為現在被正式地設計成一種數位服務。
嗯，你這麼說我就比較能理解一點。就像以前我們可能會把想買的東西截圖下來，存在手機裡幻想一下。
對，原文有提到，丹麥高等研究院的教授 Shriram Venkatraman 說，這種行為本身很普遍，不是韓國特有。很多人都曾瀏覽沒買、把東西加到購物車又放著。
那如果我是創業者，或者公司主管，能從這裡學到什麼？總不能開一個網站讓大家空逛吧？
我覺得最關鍵的是，我們可以把消費行為拆解開來。很多時候，人們喜歡的不是「擁有」，而是「挑選」、「比較」、「期待」的過程。
你是說，即使沒有最終的交易，我們也能在某些環節創造價值？那具體怎麼做？賣「體驗費」？
比如說，零售業可以考慮推出一些「體驗式服務」，不以實際銷售商品為目的。像是服飾店可以設計「虛擬試衣」體驗，讓顧客嘗試不同搭配，就算不買也覺得有趣。
但這樣成本不會很高嗎？弄一堆虛擬的服務，最終沒能導向銷售，對公司來說還是負擔吧？
這就要看怎麼設計了。比如像咖啡店，可以提供「策展型」的菜單。每天推出不同風味組合，讓顧客享受「選擇」的樂趣，而不是只是點一杯咖啡。
我猜啦，這種模式可能更適合一些高價位的、非必需品。讓大家先體驗那種「擁有」的想像，建立品牌好感度，未來等到他們有能力購買時，就會想到你。
其實上班族也能把這個概念帶入工作。例如，做企劃的時候，可以試著把產品或服務的「體驗環節」拉出來，單獨思考怎麼優化。
你的意思是，跳脫「最終成果」的框架，去思考過程中的每一個環節，看能不能從中發掘新的價值？
沒錯。就像很多會議，大家可能更享受發想、討論的過程，而不是真的要立刻做出決定。
嗯，這點我是信了。有些時候開會，確實只是想把想法說出來，聽聽別人的意見，那個交流的過程就很有收穫。
所以，這個案例好像也提醒了我們，很多看似沒效率的行為，背後可能藏著新的需求。
或許我們該重新審視那些過去認為是「浪費時間」的行為，搞不好裡面就有新的商機。